well I think is we have got so used to
seeing uh zelenski addressing world
leaders and Gatherings by video I think
it will be quite a moment for us to see
him in person leaving the country the
first trip he'll be making and
addressing both houses of Congress in
Washington also meeting the president of
course and holding a press conference
um he is going at a time when I think
we've seen the 300th day of the war pass
yesterday we're entering a period on our
weather is I think a sense that a fear
that fatigue may be setting in the west
War fatigue and a knowledge of course
that Putin will be doing what he can
over the winter to drive a wage between
allies so this is the moment Americans
of ukrainians have decided it is the
right time for zelenski to take what is
undoubtedly some kind of risk to travel
to Washington to go there with a message
he says of strength and resilience I
think there is a fear at the moment here
at least that the West is
underestimating Vladimir Putin still and
has not done enough to neutralize and
repel the danger of him dismantling the
power grid here and the Damage that is
is doing on the home front a Relentless
wave of missiles and drones is
destroying the power facilities here
cutting off major cities from Power
completely or at least restricting
electricity supplies and that is
undoubtedly over the winter going to be
a danger a sort of mortal danger to many
ukrainians who will be freezing
literally in the homes but also to the
morale and spirit I think of those
relatives who are fighting on the front
line I think militarily as well there is
a sense that the Americans that the
Americans are and still underestimating
Putin in terms of what the ukrainians
need to fight him they know that the
Russians have suffered catastrophic
losses and blunders for month after
month from this war but I think there is
a feeling now that the Russians are
possibly getting their acts together
they're using their old tried and tested
methods of sending wave after waves of
troops against the ukrainians with a not
apparent much compassion for their own
soldiers but that is grinding down and
degrading ukrainians who I I think feel
that they are being given and by the
West just enough to continue this war
but not to finish it or to win it and
therefore the key message we've been
hearing here and undoubtedly one that
zelenski will take to Washington with
him is they need more weapons if the
West wants this war to end in the way
that it does